it was the Oh bellybutton piercing hey
guys my name is grace Helbig if you do
not know now you know you're like it's
different now I went on my Facebook page
and ask you guys what kind of video did
you want to see for today because it's
really important for me to make you guys
feel like you are really a part of this
channel I look through all of your
suggestions it were amazing really
provoking in the thought Department
especially one suggestion I like things
on your head that have never been on
your head before the Internet is for
pushing the envelope starting
conversation creating connections let's
do this
hair time is so uninteresting local
newspaper
olympic-themed dog wristband folks zero
a very pinterest desk straw caramel
vanilla cream Keurig cup dirty sock
Pizza flavored Pringles a light bulb
hair straightener 100% natural no
aluminum no paraben vanilla lemon
flavored deodorant George I've done
crunches peanut butter crunch but dirty
cutting board in the shape of New Jersey
a sweater I was wearing earlier today at
funds that are missing one of their
jelly ear pieces and make them very
impractical and equally impractical
golden French Bulldog shave tape
dispenser a wireless keyboard wireless
mouse Ireland's mirror the rechargeable
vibrator an oversized purse from H&M
perfect thanks a Beautyblender any line
of baked glosses a dog bed casual summer
sneaker a handheld clothing steamer of
college friend's wedding invitation
tampons squatty potty my laptop this one
is actually the most terrifying one I'm
gonna take it off earful scissor Djinn
dolphins newest book a hairdryer a
replica of a Native American Papoose
that I made for a fourth-grade project a
puss is basically like a Native American
baby bjorn and but I made it I mean I
watched my dad make it on my behalf with
well-intentioned fraternal instincts
look how well tell them and look at
where I am now I don't think my dad ever
thought when he was making this Papoose
for me in fourth grade that this would
be where it ended up in my life okay wow
wow there are
all the things that I will be balancing
on my head for this video this has been
quite a roller coaster I have never used
my heads as much in the video ever
thanks for the opportunity hey here's a
thought
continuing the use of my head I think
that this is a challenge / video idea
that needs to be spread throughout the
YouTube space if you guys agree with me
give this video a thumbs up I want to
challenge some of the youtubers to this
head balance challenge that we're gonna
call it head balance challenge short
head balance challenge
why not I'm tagging some youtubers in
this innovative groundbreaking challenge
I'm tagging Hannah Hart will the Borg
kollene Ballinger glozell and I'm
tagging the vlogbrothers either one both
whatever we can get so there are people
I challenge to the head balance
challenge it will change you so just you
know go into it with an open mind if you
guys enjoyed this video or if you hated
it so so deeply don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel or you
can click on this button and subscribe
I'm happy that you would even like
consider doing it so thanks for being
here uh I don't know oh no no caught it
oh no no no not you my Oh glass just
okay hard to do oh oh oh my god I think
I have a square head oh no a portrait of
my mother signed by my own mother giving
me as Christmas close enough